tu veux qu'on se voit qu'on se tutoie
moi j'ai le vouvoiement c'est une
éducation ça n'a rien
d'autun ouais mais j'avoue je veux voir
plus facilement donc on va t'envoyer
j'avais le droit de mettre vous êtes
noir vous voyez je mets mes lunettes
d'accord quand tu as fait une chanson
que j'adorais qui s'appelait je suis une
catin si je suis libertine waimes il y
avait je suis une cataracte 1 et alors
maintenant il y en a une autre c'est je
suis un garçon j'ai un mouchoir dans mon
pantalon je suis le chevalier d'eon en
fait que j'aurais venu c'est un cas des
mines ouais
la prochaine fois ça va être quoi je
suis un caméléon non c'est un show c'est
dans la chanson déjà plus d'un quart
sont pas ce qui l'inquiète
la prochaine fois ça va être quoi une
fois encore prochaine verra pas
seulement l'iphone est temps de travail
devraient faire du flamenco
sinon c'est bon alors je t'ai vu chez
denisot un soir tu choisisses et des
photos qui choisissait exprès des photos
avec un mec qui avait des têtes coupées
à la main au vietnam qui les mettait
dans une tombe comme ça c'était c'était
c'était sanglant c'était saignant
c'était violent
et tu disais que tu aimais bien ça non
ça c'est enfin je peux je l'ait
peut-être dit mais ça c'est dans le sait
les émissions en direct que je voudrais
dire là dessus c'est que j'ai une
fascination pour ça j'aime ça je ne suis
ni sadique ni folle ouais j'aime en
tassant ça peut-être un peu mais quand
hassan
beaucoup de respect c'est certainement
un propos qui a pu choquer certaines
personnes
moi ça m'a pacha
que je sois oui attiré par sa
certainement que j'aime ça c'est un
débat qui compte du complexe quand je
t'ai vu aux oscars de la mode qui chante
et déshabillez moi et à un moment tout
habillé tout en noir et à un moment je
sais pas une position bien oui il y
avait une petite culotte blanche
c'est fait exprès des trucs comme ça ce
n'est pas une petite culotte on est
habillé tout en noir comment pourrais je
savoir que le caméraman place saq m'at
on dit songer jean paul jaud cappelle en
pévèle les bars à la fin de la chanson
et quels seins qui tombent s'étaient
préparés ou pas préparer moi je me
demande des trucs comme ça je suis lâche
maïs également j'ai vu les dents tu me
laisses dans un
c'est sûr j'ai lu une interview de
franck maubert dayer dans le matin où tu
disais que tu habitais avec un singe
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais un singe
c'est un s'agit s'est passé ajouté +16
ici
et c'est un petit singe qui est grand
comme ça qui est très longue queue et
qui est adorable caractériel et que
j'aime prendre et tu disais que tu
aimais bien le singe parce qu'il y avait
quatre mains c'est quand on lit des
trucs comme ça au journal c'est
vachement sympa mais ça me choque
aujourd'hui on passe quand on vous pose
la question pourquoi aimez-vous les
singes c'est vrai que c'est difficile ça
paraît tellement évident c'est vrai que
non seulement il à quatre mains c'est à
dire qu'il peut vraiment
tripoter tous les objets reproduire tout
ce que vous pouvez écrire lire enfin ça
c'est assez étonnant
mais ce n'est pas que ça c'est un singe
c'est fascinant parce que c'est vraiment
terriblement proche de l'homme mais
c'est un mini cakes sept mois sauf qu'il
a 4 dont tu peux faire vivre avec la
sage qu'avec un homme tu n'es pas avec
un câble tv toutes ses lecteurs me
verrais pas pourquoi parce que ça c'est
quelque chose que je vais faire un bon
café très tu fais très attention à ta
bille ma vie privée j'ai très attention
à ton image finalement je sais pas si
c'est faire très attention je crois que
je n'ai aucun plaisir
à parler de ça voilà c'est quoi ton
plaisir mon plaisir c'est de chanter
c'est le cinéma c'est la musique c'est
une affaire de son aventure
je ne sais pas j'aime aller au cinéma
dans les médias pourquoi pas le signer
moi je ne sais pas elle reste de ta vie
c'est quoi un partenariat avec moi à
part vous marier avec vous
je sais pas si c'est le rêve de ma vie
mais j'ai très très très envie un jour
de
d'élever des singes ah bon moi j'ai vu
un jour un portage sur diane fossey sur
saignement qui vivait au kenya les
gémeaux et c'était formidable voilà
c'est une femme qui m'a donné envie
d'élever les sites envie d'avoir plein
de petits sachets toile ils se marièrent
et eurent plein ou des orangs outans ou
des gorilles cij adopter des singes
suite malgré avec moi je ne réfléchis
pas réfléchi merci et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de l'ina l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux